so a couple people did respond to your
headshot they asked if you are mentally
unstable but at least they responded um
okay
right and also I have to say your social
media game sucks scary big-time you need
to spice it up a little bit so more
people will follow you really house I
mean my Instagram game is pretty tight
interesting just type mean awful now
because let's just see what we have here
right food food food a bridge a dead
bird food what yeah huh
really this is embarrassing okay that's
an embarrassing profile I mean a dead
bird
what if I'm naked that's not a good idea
not with your body type
hahaha what something scary from Gary
Graham I'm chilling at my crib with my
best friend of my roommate Rick he's
playing video games high on weed I'm off
to get high to like this video ladies so
baby come over I don't know what the
hell was that Amy said my social media
game sucks my instagrams whack I mean
which is totally ridiculous I told you
dude it sucks
a dead bird huh yeah yeah let me see
your phone I could help what are you
doing hey what's up it's Rick I'm here
with Gary we're about to blow up his
gram why and his face ah what the
man
now watch the videos got over 2,000
views and I have 300 new friends haha
yeah told you I know my dawg dude
now you got to keep going deliver good
you have to hurt my body every time
you want to no of course not
can't you help me without hitting me in
the face on one condition
okay what I get complete creative
control no exceptions
alright don't know if I want to give up
like ever okay you food pick post a
little bitch
okay alright alright Jesus alright you
can have complete creative control smart
smart
looking good kid these are some funny
memes Gary although my favorite is still
the one where you get slapped
Gary this photo has 10,000 likes whoa
you're in the game now all right this is
gonna make my job easier which is great
I gotta jump okay Thank You Remy bye I
love you dude holy
thank you so much you killed it did you
hear how fired up she was mmm all for
the love of the grand player all for the
love of the gram now it's time to
celebrate with a little Indonesia I
don't think we'd goes good with cereal
psych Oh Ezra hmm matcha tea tanjo munch
each time we hit lucky town headed munch
eat a my cheap
yeah hey whoa that's a lot of jalapeno
need that Bodi heat yeah that's too much
booty here we're gonna need more toilet
paper why don't we do one barbeque
I said complete creative control with
chips yeah Gary at Gary Graham yeah I
thought so you stole at skinny
goys meme bro you suck wait what
you're a piece of joke thief oh I'm
so high right now what what is he
talking about the unforgivable sin bro
I got a buddy who works at Instagram I'm
gonna get you banned for what the what's
Happ let's sing a picture no ha ha ha
I'm 278 thousand followers bro you are
you know yeah we could get some barbecue
okay now I really want to hit you with a
brick stealing are you insane
I know I'm sorry I had no idea I swear
Amy I had no idea that those were other
people's photographs I'd no idea submit
you for background work meryl streep
delete it now I will I really I'm sorry
I'm sorry I promise I'm sorry
what in the man what why did
you do that
those are other people's photographs why
don't you tag them whatever man those
guys are a bunch of nerds anyway there's
real problems going on we're in a
drought bro yeah man totally thug world
Rick dude this is my profile I just
moved to town and now I'm a thief oh
that's me at Gary Graham this is
how you tag somebody in a photo you
thief everybody chainsaw this guy's dick
off wow that's great I've got that to
look forward to this hate photo of you
has 356 thousand likes dude I'm gonna
fight this guy two people still fight is
that even happen aah what are you doing
I'm gonna name that one thief or
Sutherland ha ha
the Internet man so cool